good afternoon councilors staff uh
members of the public and the youth
Council and anybody who's decided to
zoom in uh welcome to this meeting of
the community well-being committee I'll
declare it open we have an apology for
lateness from councelor Stewart
uh an apology from Reverend cook and
councelor CRA should be joining at some
stage by zoom and P K all chair and
councelor K going to move that those are
accepted M Clark and P thank you put
that all in favor I against
carried uh let's leap ahead um and go to
the presentation of the report from the
youth Council since you've done us the
uh the honor of turning up early
welcome
along
May councilors and
representatives representative sorry my
name is Han Davis and I'm a student
at I'm from gr high and this is my first
year on Council got I'm Alexander black
from ver and this is my third year on
Council um I take our annual reporter is
read and we're just going to go over a
few of our highlights from this year
this year was my first of year on youth
Council and quickly I realized that this
was something I wanted to be heavily
involved in although the sitting was
very new and foreign to me I quickly
learned that it was a safe safe space
for individuals like me to share their
passions with each other this year I was
voted on his chair which was a very
interesting and exciting Learning lesson
for me in that area of Mah another thing
I'd like to highlight is the Mi hle
youth Focus candidates how during the
icc's election at the start of the
year I believe that this was the first
event that we held for the year and I
have to say it was one impekable night I
was thrown into the role of a judicator
um and the youth councilors there asked
a lot of questions as well as the W that
um was in
attendance I also heard that it was the
best turnout during the whole election
campaign so
Props we have a new mcot this year who I
brought with me today this is our
friendly guy Dwight the duck he shares
very inspiring and innovative ideas with
us and he actually made his way all the
way down to inago from Wellington with
one of our youth counselors Liam and I
have to add he has had the best
attendance this year of all of
us this year we've all grown together as
AO and friendships have been formed and
strengthened because of Youth Council
YY this year we had a good update with
the vaping survey that we circulated
amongst students in July we have
recently shared the survey with survey
results with the Ministry of Health
which I'm super passionate about and I'm
so excited to hear what they say if they
say anything back uh through many key
learning and civic education we have
been taught leadership qualities and
life skills and these will continue to
grow for those for all of us and
especially us on the sum summer
committee holding the for until we start
again in February
we value the full voting youth positions
offered to some of our team on Council
funding committees and have enjoyed
hearing back on funding allocations made
I'd just like to say a big thank you to
councelor llo for his outstanding
attendance to all our meetings this year
and councelor crackett for her
involvement um informative words and
another thank you to councel board for
being really encouraging and supportive
to all of our youth us youth
thank
you got um this year sadly one of our
former youth Council coordinators Ollie
Ste down but we were fortunate enough to
have Danielle come on aboard this year
and it was really amazing having
somebody else that came in with really
amazing fresh new ideas and it's been
quite a journey we opened applications
for the 2024 youth Council in September
and we've gotten over 40 applications
for 25 positions next
year we have just finished
holding our three interview sessions
with the applicants shortlisted we're
yet to make our decision on our
successful
members this year I was lucky enough to
be a part of the summer committee made
up of five of us youth counselors from
this year and we have some exciting
projects that we're going to be doing
over the summer one of these is the full
youth Council orientation day following
from a pretty successful team de
building at the Amari camp with the wire
this year
the summer committee is also planning a
youth Market Day in February so kids who
wish to sell something they've made over
the summer or maybe get some toys out of
that cupboard that Mom's been yelling
them about for a while or maybe just
make a little bit more pocket money to
give them a good start for the year can
come and have a bit of a stool um if you
do want to do it please feel free to
message us on socials to
register and we appreciate you taking
the time to listen to
us um Hana Emma thank you for your first
year I hope you have the opportunity to
continue on Alexander congratulations on
your three years and uh we wish you all
the very best for your next adventures
in in Christ Church um it's a brave
thing to step
into the world of local government when
you know there's not a lot in the way of
information or education that's that's
done outside of this process um but this
Council has been as I reflected at your
meeting very impressed with the way that
you have thought through some issues and
engaged with us and and when asked for
opinions if there wasn't one from the
council that you would point out that
there wasn't one but felt confident
enough to to share in your own and from
my observation that's been very well
received uh councilors any comments or
questions that you have for the
committee members Tom
so my question actually is about the
extent to which you feel you have
sufficient access to
council so in other words while we you
know welcome when you come and we of
course listen to what you say and we
read your reports but do you think that
the youth Council are comfortable that
you have our
year do we do you have enough
opportunity to come and speak to us is
really what I'm ask
um yeah we we're lucky enough to have
some pretty amazing counselors that come
to our meetings that we can share
insight to and they share insight to us
so that gives us a little outlet and
then of course we have these meetings
that we get to come and talk to you so I
I do think we have enough and it's
pretty amazing that we get these
opportunities thank
you grant yeah thanks chair um it's it's
always great to see you young people
here at Council and hear your view of
voice so it's really valued um and thank
you for all your efforts just thinking
through how we continue to ensure um you
know the youth voice is heard at Council
and not so much to Tom's question but
I'm interested in the bread or feedback
you're getting from youth in the city
and in initiatives you've got um to
reach as many young people as you can to
get their perspective on a city and its
future if be head any sort of thoughts
about that
or um I no right answer so I'm just
interested in your thought I think we've
gotten this year has gotten better but I
think we can always get better and a way
that we're trying to do this is from the
uh day that we the market day that we're
doing in summer we want people to know
that there's a youth Council there's a
lot of people don't actually know so
we're trying to get the name but I think
this yeah always room for improvement
something we want to grow social media
yeah so this year we have um uh Jim and
Danielle have led us uh had more access
to the social media so we have um kind
of Taken control of that not yet in a
way but um yeah we do want to get more
out there and social medias probably so
how many people would follow you or
engage with you on social media
regularly um I can speak to that
actually seeing as we have opened up the
social media accounts most of the that
we got for this year came from
engagement on our social media accounts
which we got over 40 applications which
is very impressive so I'd say what we're
doing at the moment is working out quite
well yeah yeah but you don't record
numbers or level of penetration into
they don't have access to that Grant
they don't no so you're going to get
them access given you're the senior
counselor no that's held by the
Communications Department right yeah the
analytics well you know reality is it's
an important channel that young people
communicate in and on and through and so
a youth Council need to be connected to
something yeah but it's no different to
any other staff member who who doesn't
have access to to the analytics and it's
not a disrespectful thing it's control
over the device if there's information
they need to know all they've got to do
and it'll be provided is ask and it'll
be provided but just open access to any
social media
account somebody can put something up
thinking it was hilarious and it's all
over the front
page um well I think one of the other
Innovations actually that's coming uh
which the youth Council has touched on
is also the summer committee so that's
um so that they're continuing over
what's normally a several month break so
they've got that momentum uh for those
who have done their first year and want
to continue through and as they
mentioned they've got their project
coming up in February so that's some
some Innovation as well Trish um I'm
really impressed with the number of
people you've got to interview for the
Youth Council have you given any thought
to the people who are't successful will
you keep their names sort of in a some
kind of data base for you to be able to
engage in the forward projects that
you're
doing Jimma do you want to have a crack
at
that C thank you um thank you councilor
Bo for your question yes so um Danielle
and myself are keeping a list of the
unsuccessful people and we have let them
know that they will be provided with um
an opportunity should we have a youth
Council resign during the year or should
there be a community board wishing to
get a youth rep on board we could tap
into that um that resource um of those
that were unable to make the 25 it's
amazing that you've been a to do
that
P
um just my question is really around I'm
interested in your Youth and wellbeing
committee and the in the things that you
are planning for you know for the year
over Christmas period and into next year
but are some of those sort of like
ideas that you may have in the
pipeline do you mean a summer comme no
the youth well-being committee that you
wrote about within the annual
report I'm just really interested in
some of maybe activities or that you
reach young people that are at risk for
requiring support in the
community okay so it's not going over a
summer the wellbeing committee it was
just this year but soorry can you just
repeat your question sorry oh my
question I'm just really interested in
maybe any up up and cominging activities
that you may have in the pipeline oh
yeah so I think um we'll probably wait
until uh February when we start next
year with the new uh youth counselors
and and see where we take it from there
okay thank you but we definitely well I
definitely want to do something with it
so so by way of explanation the youth
Council as a whole has planned that
event in February but for each of the
Committees they try and keep things
within within the year it's difficult
sometimes to transfer some of those
other things over but they'll start the
24 year with those who are interested in
Youth and wellbe and looking uh to see
what their key issues are what projects
they want to work on so early in the
year is a good time to get to them oh I
thank you for clarifying that R um thank
you for your um indepth report I'm
interested of the community advocacy and
volunteering committee and I note that
the important areas that you touched on
this in your last year has been the
vaping climate change and social
wellbeing but also note that um you've
mentioned um when you verbalized that
not a lot of the community knows that we
do have a youth Council so what are the
sorts of strategic um planning will you
look at to engage and say like your high
schools your sports days um and
significant school days that you can
kind of get in there and speak to those
students about what it is that you do to
bring more
awareness um so we have had a few youth
counselors go to their schools and talk
to their school about it um I'm sure we
can look at doing some more events about
youth Council we have had some quite on
the social media from what we can see
we've had some quite good growth in it
we've had more with the 40 applicants we
can see that it's getting outreached
there are people seeing it um personally
I know that people have gone into
schools cuz I've I've definitely at
least talked to my school about it and
people so we're trying to in our own
schools get it but there's we haven't
had like a set of end about hey we're
here where the you Council come we've
got all our meetings are always open
anyone's happy to come join but I'm sure
we can look at doing some open days or
anything of yeah that's what you're kind
of wanting to see yeah that'll be cool
although it's not for us to tell them
what to do no that's correct say that
that would be cool but that's actually
up to you um to be fair the the the
youth Council does look at what it feels
is going to be relevant to do and looks
for opportunities for things that
happening within schools to see what
they can leap in and capitalize it
depends on on the members side you've
got some people who are new to it and
possibly still learning and not that
outgoing and there are others who are
just confident to you know put it out
there um so it it really depends on on
the individuals but they are well
supported yeah it's F tested thank you
any other question oh sorry M CL and
question question for you chair um I
just wondered whether if you listen to
what Tom said about uh Council listening
to youth Council whether there's an
opportunity for our four committees
which are not decision-making to have a
youth Council representative attend so
it could be that a youth representative
could attend each of the four Council
committees so say a three- Monon period
and then swap it over somebody else so
you you probably engage at least half
the group that way by the actual nuts
and bolts of coming to a council meeting
most of them are 3:00 onwards one one
being the exception of course but I'm
sure you could get out of school for the
early one um where that's an experience
that could be potentially offered in the
future I I guess because they're open
meetings it's something that can be
explored whether or not there's speaking
rights certainly isn't voting rights um
but in the last year I think we had um
in the early stages of some of our
long-term planning we had a a youth
Council representative long to to the
workshops and engag so if there are
those opportunities that they're
interested in attending and and
attending then um we can work through
Jimma to make that happen y I think it'
be helpful if they could be engaged and
with speaking right at the at the
committee level that you know be tackled
about their views when the items come up
so they have to be a little bit prepared
I guess the the challenge is whose view
are you listening to so we're there as
elected representatives each with an
individual mandate versus them as
somebody who might not have a direction
from the youth Council on how youth
Council wants to go but as we've seen
they certainly have their own opinions
and might like to share those so maybe
that's something they might like to kick
around when they form in the new year I
guess When we struggle to get youth
involved in politics both local and
National they tend not to vote and this
to me this would be an opportunity of
them seeing a very younger much younger
face interesting that Nelson the deputy
me is about 20 um really innovating when
he gets up to speak at national
conferences people really sit and
list maybe some options for some that
want to do
that um we'll kick that around with the
new Council when it forms in the new
year and see what opportunities they'd
like to take but we will put that to
them Steve I just want to say Well done
I've been here for a short time but um
having s pressed and you're right
that that byelection uh campaign meeting
that we had was was so impressive um
just the turn up but also the the
thoughtful questions and work that have
been done and behind the scenes to to
um yeah to bring to that meeting um and
it's been a real privilege sitting in on
the meetings that I had been to over the
last few months just out of Interest
really this might be more for for jimer
as well but those 40 applicants
congratulations on that firstly and and
good work on your social media I've I've
been following and seeing what you've
been doing um
how did we go in terms of I guess age
the age span and also just covering of
of in theago schools just interested in
in how we went on
that
level C Brad um yeah so given that' done
most of the interviews you probably had
a fair idea but um actually a lot of
younger applicants we did a a we boost
didn't we at one of the junior campuses
um we we saw a lot of 12 and 13 year
olds come through um lots of girls
students but a make up across the
schools um including two Representatives
that were studying or um in Mahi that
were around 19 and 20 years old so we
run from 12 to 24 we did see quite a
diverse range of applications this round
not as diverse as we'd like but we're
getting there yeah oh great thank
you thank you any further questions or
comments if not the recommendation is
that we received the report the 2023
youth Council annual report which I'll
move Z second P thank you put that all
in favor I carried thank you
Med great Christmas thank
you councils that brings us back to Tab
four the minutes of the community
well-being fund sub
committee
and councilor crackett was Mo thank you
Mr CH counc so
seconded councelor Bond thank you sorry
yes be see yes you should be yes I was
there uh any questions or
comments if not I'll put that all in
favor I I against carried Community
well-being committee from October 10
I'll move there a second second Council
SOA any issues yes I was present at the
me I was an apology for the
meeting thank you we'll note
that than Amendment any other
sorry um I might have that wrong one of
them so it's the minutes from the 28th
September no no Bigg part the one
before all
right uh you you your apology is in the
your fund subcommittee oh sorry we've
gone from that to this
committee so no changes
no issues Grant no Lesly seconded um put
that all in favor against carried
extraordinary uh well-being fund
subcommittee from October 20 Council
Bo
second I move there sorry thank you and
seconded councelor SOA any questions or
issues but that all in favor I I
against carried uh we've got the minutes
of the district licensing committee from
October which I'll move see seconded
Council Bond any
queries move all in favor I against
carried we've got the minutes of the
gambling policies hearing held uh last
week which includes the
recommendation
um that is a recommend ation that would
go from this committee through to
council for approval the process is you
either move it or
not and then the same will apply at
Council move councel Campbell and
seconded councel bond any
questions just just a reflection chair I
think it's um I couldn't attend but um
for a lay person reading the minutes and
some of the submissions was very
confusing I think some people got um
some distorted information around what
we were attempting to do was the first
issue and secondly um around how much
money actually comes out of a pokey
machine at the end of the day so I was
really pleased with the outcomes um I've
had some experience in dealing with
problem gamblers um and I think the the
cap with a shift to the CBD where that
cap needs to apply I think it's a really
good outcome I'm not sure what I agree
with 14 or 15 venues being high desel or
high de probation areas but but I think
the outcome was very was very good for
for our community across each time we've
from when we bought the policy into each
time when we reviewed it it is um
because of the seriousness of of
gambling harm quite often a very emotive
issue um but one that we um received and
debated in public y thank
you sorry did I get a
mo did yes thank you put that then all
in favor I against
carried andago City council's tree
plan welcome along
Caroline k um so the tree management was
raised at a previous Community wellbe
Committee and therefore brought this
paper back to the committee just just an
update because um changes in the council
and such like so it was actually created
um to ensure that our trees are managed
and proactively in the best way possible
for the future there was a the tree plan
itself for 2020 was drafted after
consultation with manaen Council staff
and key stakeholders and our long-term
priority is to have an appealing and
sustainable network of diverse tree
species of varying ages and stages the
plan itself um focused on us having a
clear direction of strategy undertak an
inventory of all of our street trees and
also providing policy guidance for
removals and renewals in the future and
ensuring that's a consistent to
consistent approach to trees on our
Council land the um with us having that
aging tree Network and um the plan
enables us to have a more proactively
and effectively managed trees for the
future one of the key actions that we
needed to take was to undertake some
more annual scoping um and more of a
risk assessment of the Heritage trees in
areas and those were probably why the um
committee brought that up at the last
meeting around how we managing those
trees and also obviously the
um the airport activity over Queens Park
was one of the other issues that we were
asked to look into so I've brought back
an update as to how we're managing that
um piece of work uh that piece of work
been we'd been asked to remove the 227
trees um and a over the next few years
uh we've got 44 of those have currently
been removed alongside our renewal
program so we're doing that quite
proactively um and we're looking to
review this entire plan for 2025 we have
found that the the plan itself um
enables us to remove trees quite well
but sometimes the replacement of those
back into utility corridors has been
quite challenging so our our next steps
have been that in-depth assessment of
the trees in the in the high-risk areas
and the say high risk those that have
got high volume either people or
traffic we've done um that assessment
has been done we don't have the report
back for us yet it was undertaken last
week um approximately 450 trees were um
were reviewed with that um with an
indepth assessment we undertook the
immediate removal of one that was deemed
dangerous and we were awaiting the
management plans for any remainder
however the majority of the remainder
have been deemed to be in good health
and well managed just waiting for some
more specifics on those
areas so when we get to the review in
2025 we'll bring that back to the
council for um updates ideas and ensure
that we go back out to the community for
more um more consultation on the things
that they found since we put it in place
in
2020 thank you would be interesting if
we could get an update on that
assessment when it's complete y if that
could come back to us next
year
M CL um so on
page um 42 of board books it refers to
the purpose of the tree plan being to
look after 5,000 trees and we're going
to get a later report um about um the
activity report that says I think that
um and this year we've planted nearly
10,000 trees I think 9,500 so the
question I guess is do we not manage
those trees that we're planting they
just planted and left or do we just have
an obligation to the 5,000 trees that
are listed
there thank you M Clark the um the 5000
trees it's actually um it's between 5
and 6,000 and those are the street trees
so those are the trees in the utility
corridors that we specifically did the
inventory for which is why we know the
exact number okay okay two two other
quick questions um on page 47 it refers
to um point bullet point two about
showcasing theago SL Miku just a minor
technicality should that be as
opposed to Miku which is much wider than
just the
city we need to incorporate our
do yep and the very last one I get in
before Leslie gets in because she always
picks up the typing mistakes I think on
page 53 the word dying is actually
misspelled it shouldn't have the e in it
halfway down when it talks about live
dead and dying and decaying like dying
actually something to do with coloring
yeah they could be colored
could yeah
trees thank
you
um this doesn't include any of the
forestry top trees at Sandy Point no it
doesn't no no the the forestry trees are
managed under the Sandy Point domain
management plan yeah yeah so the
references into some areas of Sandy por
are specifically related to those
recreational areas ands around
environmental areas and recreational
areas yes in terms of monitoring how
many trees have fallen in the network as
a result of um weather events or um you
know at rust trees that have actually
Fallen do we know that no we don't CC
ter it's not a it's not a statistic that
we currently monitor for yeah because
there's been quite a few on Queen Park
in recent weather events so we do have
an inventory of the trees in Queens Park
they aren't actually live on the gis
Network just yet it's still a piece of
work um it's a work in progress as part
of the tree plan yeah so we will be able
to say how many of those have been
removed or have come down since the
inventory was undertaken but we don't
specifically monitor for that
data so the person that's doing the risk
assessment how are you identifying the
trees that he's going to see so they
were done that was the the high volume
areas the areas where we do have most
either traffic or people so Queens Park
a lot of the trees and queen Parks were
undertaken also those on the traffic
corridors so we identified um self
identified about we started off with
about 200 trees but that's extended as
we've um as he's come on board and
looked at the actual areas that we're
looking at okay so given that we're
going to commission someone to do an
inspection shouldn't we then measure how
um close to um a forecast we are in
terms of if we say there's 200 trees and
a tree 10% of trees fall outside of
those identified trees then clearly our
identification of rust trees isn't quite
as accurate as it should be is that a fe
assumption to make um we've just done a
new assessment so something that we
could look at to the Future yeah that's
what I mean going forward how are you
going to monitor your sort of assessment
accuracy we could definitely take that
on
board so you are going to monitor
it we will look to how we can actually
identify that data and make sure that we
align it with the other inventories that
we've got yeah because I think it's
pretty important because there's an
element of Public Safety here right so
the tree falls over that we haven't
classified in an exercise or we have
identified it as not a risk and it does
fall over then you know obviously
there's a bit of
issue think the higher risk areas are
the ones that that get priority I
guess one of the things that would have
to be considered from a management point
of view operationally is if you're going
to
extend what's monitored and counted um
which budget are we plucking that from
well the point is if we're hiring
someone to do a specific role how
competent are they well it's also around
the scope of work because I could if
you're pushing the thank you if you're
pushing the scope of workout obviously
it's going to cost more but we but the
report says we're going to get a
specialist to do
it yes right so wouldn't we expect some
sort of level of Competency with that
specialist to be able to identify a tree
and have some level of accuracy around
what a risky tree looks like Mr day yeah
thank you through yourself chair just
wanted to highlight um which was said
earlier in relation to you've got to do
a risk assessment and relation to where
the tree is falling um tree falling in a
forest that has nobody going through it
is a lower risk than a tree where um
your pedestrians are going past all the
time well that doesn't take a rocket s
to work that out though doesn't correct
um and that's exactly what um Carolyn
highlighted um through that initial
assessment was that it was initially 200
trees which would deemed um to be in the
highrisk traffic areas from our
perspective they widened the scope in
relation to some of the other
discussions that happened at Council to
increase that to 450 trees um but our
Focus has been on the Public Safety in
relation to the the tree areas um not an
all it's not a full tree coverage it
does come down to what can you do from a
financial and where's the public truly
at risk in relation to that so that
assessment's being taken yeah but to my
point so there's trees falling down in
Queen Park were they on the RIS register
have they not been
assisted cuz they're pretty big trees
and they fall across golf courses in
places like that just happens to be that
there's no one around at night well
that's
lucky well I guess part of the yes they
will have B on the risk register because
they're in Queens Park and I think
Caroline's already identified that those
trees in those major therapies are on
the watch anyway but there have also so
been some exceptional weather events and
so if the scale of the weather events is
higher than than we've experienced
that's going to create anomalies that
that might catch us out I guess one of
the things that we need to consider is
as a result of climate change and
changing weather fat that that might be
something that we need to well surely
that's what your experts doing isn't it
because they've taking that into account
when they're doing their assessment I
would have thought if we were the only
place in New Zealand where trees were
falling over during those exceptional
weather events I think would be
concerned but there were quite a few
places that were caught by them not just
us I'm not saying that I'm saying if
we're getting a specialist look at
it they surely identifying trees that
are you know prone to a certain level of
wind in a certain type of event yeah
which brings us back to where we started
every tree or the trees in the high risk
areas because if it's every tree we're
going to upscale the budget well it's
not every tree is it well that was the
question I just asked so if we're
looking at the high risk areas then then
absolutely that's that's where we want
to make sure we've got it
Focus Leslie and then Ria and then Tom
welcome Barry thank you thank you Mr
Cher I was just going to um remind
people of some of the history which
predates some councilors at table of why
we've got the tree plan at all um so it
was I
believe the event some years ago of
several trees coming down in Queens Park
close to the museum and structure cheer
and Deputy chair of the time I think
that was councilors Thomas and pottinger
um who raise the fact that we didn't
have the sort of inventory um that
formed into the tree plan so that's the
history so it was always intended that
the highest
risk
trees be addressed that was where the
200 came from as C said it got extended
to about 400
50 um and it was a new and developing
plan that was meant to prepare us much
better than we were prepared where it
was more of a an exercise of clearing up
some Fallen trees that had come down in
various areas I think we had another
incident of some coming down at Donovan
Park um fortunately in a not
particularly populated
area so the the history was was that the
tree plan was quite recent it was
inspired by events that were largely in
Queens Park and it was certainly
intended that it targeted the high risk
trees and gave us an inventory and a way
of checking um even on an annual basis
that we had the
identified highest risk
trees and I realized there have been
some fairly heavy weather events um but
I had understood that it was that yearly
expert Lo to just ensure that we
had things at the risk level there
should be at per Caroline can confirm
and that yearly check was done last week
yeah thank you and that's what we're
waiting for the full report from we've
just had some verbal updates so far and
that was done by The Specialist it was
thank you that's that was my
understanding um thank you Caroline for
um your report and also the attach tree
plan that um is an update from last time
thank Ley for the history but what I was
looking at um is the in airport limited
request to remove Queens Park trees to
65 of those a high priority trees out of
227 trees over the 2-year
period um 44 of those trees have been
fouled or removed um I'm interested when
you said about i' call it
repopulation I'm assuming that the trees
that will replace those are sufficient
for the area that they're going back
into so that we don't find
in my kid's generation when they're
sitting around this table we going to
chop them back down again so are we
prioritizing the species of trees
absolutely we are that's great
absolutely that's what the tree plan
enables us to do to actually be U more
specific around the trees that are
placed yeah so that's really good the
other thing I wanted to question is do
you think that these trees these high
priority RIS trees that they will be de
to every 2-year period is sufficient
enough do they need to come down prior
to that given we are in a weather pent
at the moment that is going to be high
winds and that's a great question that's
why it would be really good if I can
come back when the report has been
received from specialist because I'm
expecting some management plans to come
from from him I as I say he's he's
indicated verbally that majority of the
trees are in good health there may be
some remedial action but we've only had
that one tree that we were asked to
remove
iMed advised to remove immediately right
so there were two trees removed one tree
sorry on the weekend um at the golf
course that um so when the trees are
removed I'm sorry if this is an
operational question how quickly is it
that that whole area is tied up so that
there is no debris left over for anyone
to hurt themselves
on um that the single tree that came
down had to come down as we say quite
quickly there are a number of others
there that we would like to take down
but they were not as urgent as that one
so when that whole area has been um
remediated then it will be cleaned up so
the whole lot will be moved at once a
number I'm not quite sure exactly how
many are coming from the area but we
took out the one immediately okay thank
you
Tom thank you chair um Caroline people
feel very protective of trees as we want
them to be and it's a whole reason
really for having this policy can you
just clarify though whether we ever
remove um a non native trees um to
replace them with indigenous trees and
and only for that reason not that I'm
aware of no okay thank you because there
is a belief that that happens but it it
doesn't so we don't replace mature Oaks
with just because it happens because we
want to replace it with an indigenous
tree no that wouldn't happen C no okay
thank you good question that Barry yes
far as the trees at I was North End
Bowling Club during the weekend there's
a row of trees and I believe they are
going to come down because there a
walkway going to the museum is there a
time span on there when those trees are
going to be removed I don't have that
with me councelor Stewart to tell you
that they're huge those ones if they
come down they'll take that b Club out
anyway well they're not the only ones
yeah as you pointed out there some nice
nice biggies on Alice Road as well and
Dawn Street yeah uh ring thanks Cher um
my question is around um uh Street trees
and Council infrastructure such as foot
paths um the other morning I think was
yesterday morning I ran down Swinton
Street and never been down there before
but had to divert to the road to run on
because the foot path had looked like
had undergone a massive seismic activity
it was like a it was like a ripple and
it on looking at it more closely it was
the roots from the the trees breaking
right through across through the
footpath underneath it towards the house
so what happens there does
infrastructure come along and replace
the foot path and kill trees because
obviously the roots will have to be
taken out or how do you how do you work
through that cuz it is a beautiful
Treeline
street but those roots have just gone
it's the foot path is made of some sort
of T tar seal or something like that I I
would think that was actually an
infrastructure matter because we would
take advice from infrastructure managers
as to what they needed well it's a Tre
but we don't want to kill trees so where
do we where do we that's why I'm raising
it now smooth pavement or no no no with
the roots if we've got to chop The Roots
off at all the east facing rout uh west
facing Roots that's not going to be good
for the tree not going to be good for
them in the wind either no no no that's
what I mean so how do we how do we work
this usually on a Case by case basis
councel Po and I mean it's a whole
street so we're talking two
blocks I couldn't tell you specifically
but it's usually a very um significant
conversation between ourselves and
infrastructure okay and we you know
obviously the the value of the trees to
those um to the community there is very
high um and so we would involve the
community in any decision to remove any
amount of trees I actually couldn't
believe that no one's complained
seriously uh you could not a person and
a roller or Walker or whatever could not
Traverse say knew they were worried they
would lose the trees I don't know CU
they do look spectacular we'll we'll see
it in the December infrastructure
meeting thank you any other questions or
comments if not would somebody like to
move that we receive the report and
acknowledges the issues that council is
plan to overcome Leslie and Trish put
there all in favor I against carried
excent um good Tab 10 is
the uh temporary alcohol ban which goes
in for Christmas at the races again this
is just um procedural and something we
go through each year uh jilan is there
anything you want to add to the
report that pretty much covers it
councelor llo uh probably the only
additional information this year is that
uh in the past we Council has shared the
cost of the signage uh for the tempor
alcohol ban with s and Racing Club and
we've spoken with the racing Club this
year and they have agreed that from 2024
event onwards that they'll cover the
full cost of that the cost of that this
year is $1300 that will be sheded
between Council and the racing
Club thank you there's two
recommendations there's a
Move May Clark and rear any further
questions or
comments if not I put the motion all in
favor I I against carried thanks
Julian Ranna update to the framework for
the community well-being
fund K chair counselors um so this
report really is an opportunity both to
provide an update on um the work that
the fund has done and an update on the
framework itself
um the fund committee has met they've
workshopped um what some improvements
they would like to make to the way that
the fund operates and they're
recommending those through to this
committee for your consideration today
um those are to bring the fund into
alignment with the council's new updated
strategic framework for this long-term
plan so such as a small minor change
around the way that the well-beings and
the scoring is structured um and then
some minor administrative of
changes um so we're just seeing up on
the screen now just an overview of some
of the great projects and outcomes that
the fund has supported to scroll
please um so this is just a good
opportunity just to celebrate all the
amazing Mahi and the community that the
fund has supported and
enabled
um I'll just take the report as read and
the chair of the committee may wish TR
to say something anything you'd like to
add I would like to acknowledge the work
that Jimma does it's totally outstanding
um it's presented to us in such a way as
that we we have a very clear picture of
what's what we're doing and um meetings
are great they're it's a real privilege
to be part of them and I think they
they're well managed so thank you
nothing I have nothing to add otherwise
thank
you uh four recommendations Trish you
wanting to move them yes I'd like to
have them thank thank you seconded by
Ria it's open for questions
councilors M Clark yeah and I um just
wanted to know from the chair of the
thing just a couple of questions about
the uh allocations that were made um the
one on the south sea spray trust is that
in this financial year one that we're
currently in or is it the previous
Financial year I think it was previous
is it yes previous previous that's okay
cuz I know they they're going out to
winon um and the other one for me was I
guess a little bit un ease about
um uh contributing to a uh green ACR
Country Club practice green development
um I suppose it meets the criteria but
in some ways it's a little bit like does
that open us up to just about every
Sports Club wanting to have some
development as well
I think you can be sure that these are
debated very clearly sure understand and
that um that definitely is foremost when
we do make decisions um I'm comfortable
in the decisions that have been made
would somebody else from the committee
like to make a comment absolutely I mean
I think um I understand what you're
saying yeah definitely we totally
understand what you're saying um when
they do come through with the
application it's it's fair
extensive with the information that they
provide um I don't think it will set a
president for every Golf Club to do this
because other golf clubs offer different
things to their members um but we we do
debate it and the people that we have
involved in this committee are within
our community and the information and
knowledge that they bring back through
all allows us to have that healthy
debate so I feel very confident in the
practices that we're we're doing when
we're considering applications in that
instance though just a a question
perhaps for Jimma would that been better
redirected potentially to the active
communities fund um so just through here
I just had a we look k council's um
mayor and Council Mano reps um we didn't
actually allocate them any money it as a
zero they applied to us and it was
reevaluated and they were absolutely
pointed in the direction of um some
other thank useful talk thanks
J and the last one is was TR was just
the issue of the N naked creative that
does Life magazine and I'm aware of the
magazine oh okay can you help us with
what sort of like what sort of reach
does that magazine
get same why I ask is we've got box
loads of the things sitting in
apparently South it's a money making a
money making thing we did have some um
quite a lot of discussion around this
and debate um it is given for free to
some licensing trust establishments who
funded as well it's listed as a zero
allocation any help of the
comments it's it is a zero allocation so
obviously I wasn't on the committee at
the time but obviously decision was made
definitely it's got some excellent
contributors yes thank you grant yeah
thanks she just wanted to reinforce um
tr's comments around the work that Jima
does and probably it's been hollowed in
the last couple questions just the
robustness with which that fund's
administered and um not only sort of the
way it's allocated but equally the
accountability comes back to the
committee as well so it's a very
effective committee so well done to
everyone
involved thanks for that any further
questions with full recommendations then
I put the motion all in favor I I
against carried excuse me I'm still
recovering from two weeks with no voice
which my wife thoroughly enjoyed oh L
love
that uh We've dealt with item 12 so that
brings us to speaking of which the
active communities fund update which uh
ran is um a report that we've head
through so K chair I think the report
speaks for itself this is the um first
year update from active Southland on the
funding that they um took over
Administration from from Council um and
they will be providing an annual update
in terms of how that fund Administration
has been going um just if I I can
feedback as council's rep on that
committee and I think I fed into a
workshop recently um they're doing a
really good job of broadening The
Horizon and testing the applications as
they come in um it's been a learning
process for some of the committee
members is when we get applications for
great projects that aren't specifically
in vagle and and and they're being
forced to consider well what's the
invocal component of that because that's
all that we can allocate funds to so
that was a learning for them uh for some
of the committee members but the uh
management that active Southland have
provided has been great collaborative
and reactive so we've been able to
refine it very quickly as we've gone
through pleasee thanks Mr chair I just
wanted to as the former chair of the
council's active communities fund who
transferred the funding for the very
reasons you've outlined um I've followed
the progress since we transferred the
fund with some interest and I just want
to say that I I feel that it is on track
to have done what we wanted it to do and
that it has definitely widened the
application it's allowed the
consideration
of the sporting requests holistically
with other funds um rather than us in
the old days having to say have you
approached these other funds Etc it's
allowed a much more holistic way of
dealing with things so I do feel it's on
track I I look forward to the continuing
reports but I feel it has fulfilled what
we wanted with what was the old Hillary
commission money so it is good to see it
being used um ongoingly
productively I guess it's worth um
adding that active South and also
administer the tanoa fund and because
they are you know a go-to place for
supporting
organizations um active sou and do a
pretty good job of redirecting
applicants to to the right fund as well
which has been good some have come our
way some we've shant it over to tanoa
Tom I I I was just going to ask a
question
um chair whether the previous trust um
allocated funds to registration fees or
if that's a new thing I was just a
little bit surprised to see significant
amounts of money um being allocated for
registration fees and I going to
particularly notice the southern Queens
boxing with $6,000 allocated to
registration fee so so I mean my
question is not so much about that it's
more about whether that is a change Fair
uh yes it is fair question no it
wouldn't have been previously but one of
the new directions that they have looked
at with our consent is around
accessibility um so for those for whom
um cost is an absolute barrier and and
trying to help help them overcome that
again with a city
Focus so there are things that we
wouldn't have paid for
previously uh and there's a bit of
debate goes on over the amounts as well
as you get with any funding committee
but now that is something here okay
thank
you it's been moved and seconded that we
received the
report I think no I'll move I'll move
I'll second second Les put that all in
favor against
carried thanks Jimma thanks ranan which
brings us to the activities
report Lots going on and even though we
acknowledging I think at the last
meeting it's reported on in in this uh
report about the um
staff uh here at tanaki who stayed on
during the weather events recently to to
work after ours to make sure that
everyone's calls were tended to that's
you know that's the sort of above and
beyond stuff that they weren't asked to
they wanted to um and we're really proud
of the efforts we pass that on are there
any areas in there that councilors wish
to ask questions
on M Clark um yeah two issues just one
was a reflection of the uh the food
stores that we had last Friday and and
this report back on the previous one of
September really good numbers turning
out they said uh 3,000 for the previous
event I think the one on Friday had more
than that um so it's an evolving um
Direction I guess with our city
questions to be asked about how late it
goes um whether we have more food stores
because there weren't enough I don't
think or not of the right stuff um and
whether we have an appetite to introduce
alcohol for some events as well around
the district Licensing Laws and other
things that some getting their way so
but a really positive thing and it was
pleasing that great South introduced a
local band for that event as well so
there's more there's more coming that
space the other issue was the issue of
the U that I raised before about the um
the tree planting which is on page 182
of board books um we set out a Target I
think about four or five years ago to
plant one native tree for um for every
resident in the city so that b Park
about 55
57,000 and it said in that report um the
report that we've got here that um in a
short period of time about 6 months
we've um we've planted about 95,000 so
my question was really how close are we
to that 57,000 Target or is that still
some ways
off because it would be a really nice
goal to get to R um you received an
update on that at in the Climate Change
Report I can't remember the exact figure
but it's somewhere between 20 and 26,000
trees have been planted over 3
years and I guess the last reflection I
would make is on
page3
um oh actually two Reflections um one is
the um the trail um bike tracks that
have been set up on Bluff I think
there'll be a significant um draw card
over time um certainly if you go to
Clyde you see same sort of impact there
with the tracks that are there now one
of the things that worries me is we
don't have the infrastructure and Bluff
to cope with the demand that might come
along so for say where do you park a
camp van and bluffer CU a lot of people
that do this mountain block stuff
actually have Camp Vans as well and
there seems to be nowhere
um C well that's the issue the camp the
camping ground is up for sale well it
shouldn't up for sale up for disposal I
guess and whether we can develop
something that incorporates Camp events
down there whether or not there's any
appetite and Bluff for our Go part which
is adjacent to it for part of that to be
converted don't have a heart attack
before I finish so and and it might it
might very well be that we we look to
not just take away some land but
actually give some land so the giving of
the land could be be a a pump track
that's similar to the one at OD for the
younger people and bl to plan as opposed
to going on to the hill itself so I just
think there's um potential there that
we're not quite getting
to very last thing is on the following
page which it talks about Center plot um
I get a lot of feedback from people who
say that the uh Center plots in the city
look poor they are not well managed um
and they don't have a lot of color and I
often get feedback from staff saying
well it's not that easy you to put a
safety cones around when you go do work
in them and they require a lot of work
so I was interesting I was coming back
from Den the other day and Gore I saw
the gardening woman that was there
obviously a city council employee
putting out her own cones right on the
bend and she come around by the old
police station and the way she went and
I just thought well that was really easy
um why can't we do that as well why did
it become too much I think we do as long
as there's a traffic management plan in
place yeah but the the traffic
management plan often requires a third
party you need to book and well in the
shouldn't need to okay yeah because if
there's a plan
submitted um anyone who can read the
plan should be able to go and so but
that's a that's a really good point and
um to Echo a former Council employee who
we used to give a grilling about roads
uh they can do anything you like if you
give them enough money sure um I'll
reflect on the on the
um uh Friday night even here's what I
found
ring he found
Siri I'm I'm trying to get my that's
what happens when old people interfere
with technology correct
no uh that's a good thing um license it
was well not the licensing would be a
challenge it's not insurmountable but I
guess the challenge with the uh the
night market is it's a really
familyfriendly event sure um you had
right on the cusp of it on one side the
people in NE and on other side the
people and at um at Tans who you know if
people needed a drink they knew where to
go and they didn't seem to be anyone who
was critical of it um if I had one
criticism it was probably as I was
walking past the free entertainment uh
and it was Mongolian throat singing uh
heavy Rock which wasn't really my cup of
tea y um but if you wanted to talk about
diversity and Variety in the performance
um it was look there was a really great
atmosphere a lot of people got out and
um engaged in the evening and I I would
say it was a success certainly the
improving weather makes it even better
it would be obviously a challenge over
the the winter months we come to in just
a moment P Michael yeah thank you um
chair I just want to remind counselors
that some of the center plots because I
too get some of those queries coming in
from our our public and uh some of those
Center plots don't actually fall under
council's maintenance um they're
actually um what kotahi roading
corridors but having said that there is
one that we obviously do maintain that's
on a highway one which is out near race
course and T but um I just want to
highlight that too because one of the
ones I get all the time is one of those
particular C plots so we will have
conversations to see what we can do
there thanks Michael I've got r p and
Grant thank you Mr chair I'm just
looking at page 174 of diligence and I'm
looking at the area of Environmental
Compliance and I wanted to ask a
question of what constitutes an
overground
section
Jillian a
Savana well hold on wait for my
response overground sections are dealt
with in the environmental health bylaw
uh the minimum length of um the grass
and weats has to be 25 cm before it's
considered overg
grown there will be other details but I
can't quite more health issues if there
are rats in there and the like yes okay
well the reason why I'm asking why I've
asked that question and looked at that
is um there is and maybe that's um under
a different
um B I'm not sure but from Bay Road to J
Lane we've got a sections full of cars
it's own industrial industrial right
well that was my next question so do we
have an industrial overground nope no I
ask a question is being investigated by
environment South and to see if there is
any contamination it was being
investigated a year ago I want to ask
the question well you might like to
forward that to environment sou okay
thank
you uh P I love on page
um where am I is
she page so I think it's really good
around the promotion of vegetables
growing in otor park in Queens Park here
it I mean I think I think this is a
great idea is there any consideration on
expanding where the vegetables are grown
and these types of gardens for Community
I'm just thinking of BL we have a long
strip lots of greenery on one side but
we have nothing like
this uh I know there stuff at Anderson
Park but the one in Bluff might be the
domain of wot I think again
Michael yes thank you cheer um we do
work quite proactively U the par um with
the parks team across where we have
those locations there are some Community
vegetable gardens as well from that
perspective so we're trying and get the
balance and work with the community on
those um if there suggestion that
Council want to bring forward um can
take it through to our parks and Parks
team and consider those in our next
planting
schedules thanks Grant yeah thanks CH
few um questions page 181 of B box the
tracks and trails it'll be good to see
sort of year on year um there as well
because I think it's a good indicator
around you know how our tracks are being
used and to me it's a big Wellness
indicator as well of people are active
and out and about it's a good indication
of the health of our community whereas
for some reason if they're not out then
maybe it's a insult so be good to see it
year on year now we're Gathering that we
can yeah that's right um secondly one um
183 the introduction new local pay
Advocate local play Dr
play so that's a council position
yes so given we were pretty lukewarm at
our recent workshop on sort of urban
play and we've pushed it way down the
priority list in terms of a um long-term
plan so it's a position within Council
but it's paid for by sport New Zealand
Zealand right
so we're leveraging off it and taking
advantage of their funding so it doesn't
create any additional cost in terms
of yeah it is the proverbial Gift
Horse so it' be interesting to see what
um Dr play comes up
with the challenge is you know
financially facilitating potentially
some of the suggestions that comes
forward and that comes back to the issue
that you were just talking about with
the yeah that's so do we ac you know
funding from National bodies when it
doesn't align with their long-term plan
in the immediate future I mean well
depends what options they're able to
come up with if there are low cost or no
cost options Michael uh through yourself
cheer uh look no every uh external
funding that we do get we in offer uh we
do look at it from perspective of how it
fits within the council priorities
obviously um play is something that um
Council have have an interest in um and
this allows us to get some work done
with our um Council contribution in
relation to it whether it actually ends
up leading to work that we need to um
look at and fund ongoing that is
something that would need to come back
to council um and all those cases but we
do um from our perspective we don't take
up every opportunity we do have to be um
careful about what opportunities we do
take up it's not always a gift or us um
from that perspective sometimes it's
actually a little bit of a n when you
look at it from that
perspective so we've taken funding from
National on a position hir someone but
there's no budget allocated to it
because if there's no cost or expense
associated with the role then there's no
budget allocated to
it it's fully funded from that
perspective including all the activities
they'll
undertake that's CL just one just one
question on page
186 um
and CH you've got an extensive history
in this area so you can where where the
question I guess it just seems as though
we're dragging our feet on naming TSB
and the associated trust so we've had a
bit of progress in that area but I don't
know why we make the statement the board
are also reviewing their name these are
direct that apped to a trust that we've
set up to manage the collections on a on
a regional basis we should just get on
and name whatever that trust needs to be
call it m could call it south regional
collection trust or whatever it needs to
be because well we keep dragging their
feet on that everybody thinks these
directors are involved with the museum
which they're not purely The
Collection I don't know why they've got
a meeting in December where they're
going to nominate a chair but at the
same meeting they can't decide on what
their name's going to
be I'm no longer involved Michael are
you able to surely you got a finger in a
pile there uh through through yourself
Cher um we're not in a position because
it's now not a um CCT of any sorts so
it's actually an independent trust they
have the ability and right to name name
themselves from that perspective we've
declared um we would have a preference
that they change change their name and
that has been clear the whole way
through um and was asked that they do
that as soon as possible but they want
to have a cheer in place before they
tackle that issue I know they do have it
as a high priority yeah it should be
because it's no longer the Southern
Museum and art gallery trust board it's
far far from that
so I think if um thank you if we're able
to reinforce that with them that would
be
useful re um page 178 on the venues and
events I note the rug Park um first
paragraph then coming down to the second
one does this not reading correctly the
trust was returned back to the
council so the
the ground is current was owned by the
inago city council charitable trust M
and was being vested into the ownership
of the inoco city council rather than
the trust
right I just think the way that it's
worded um is not it's ambiguous because
when I'm reading this it says that we're
currently negotiating regarding the
silent pies of rugby park and that's in
progress yep I just don't think it's
quite as one of the trustees mayor Clark
yes thank you look R I've been a trusty
H for a while I can't make head and a
tail of it either if you go back on the
history of how we inherited this rby
park I still don't understand years
later so we have to technically sell it
from the trust to the council right
that's the mechanism that we do so we're
not actually selling it we just the
ownership of it goes from charitable
trust back into core core Services yeah
I
understand I I think the intention at
the time was was that if it was vested
in a charitable trust as it had been
with rugby park previous trust um that
there was the opportunity for that trust
to be able to apply for funding but
actually I don't think the trust have
been properly set up so it created some
challenges so that's this process should
unwind that Tom I I was I mean it's the
same question I guess but I I never took
re question as been about you know why
why it was happening it was more about
the wording of the paragraph which is
which states pretty simply that we're
selling Rugby Park which is clearly not
the case so I think it's definitely open
to misinterpret
misinterpretation and just need to
clarify that as a guess we have just
done yeah yep um look to be fair I
circled it myself and going that um and
it took me a couple of minutes to unpack
what it meant so it you're quite right
the wording is i' certainly be looking
at that gift horse yeah thanks any other
items that anybody wishes to
raise if not would somebody like to move
that we receive the activities report TR
re put that all in favor against carried
there being no further items in open I
move that we go into public excluded to
discuss the minutes of the PX um part of
the community well-being fund
subcommittee September 28th public
excluded well-being committee October
10th and the public EX included
extraordinary Community well-being fund
committee on October 20 and the reasons
are under Section 72 i h g and B2 or B
II happy to second that thank you put
that all in favor I I against carried
thanks to those that have joined us on
the live stream our public excluded
session should not be taking too long so
the